at the end of the day buying and selling
stuff still gets me going in a way that
boggles my mind as many of you know if
you follow my content going to a garage
sale is still the most exciting thing I
could do in business closing an
eight-figure deal for Vayner is nowhere
on the same scale as going to a garage
sale and finding a sixty seven dollar
stuffed animal for a quarter I'm really
excited to be here for uh many different
reasons I even asked to do more q a in
this talk because I know you've been
consuming a lot of content and I think q
a always brings out the most value so
please if there's anything I touch on or
if there's anything that's been on your
mind start thinking about that because
we'll get to that in a little bit I
think most of what excites me to be here
is that at the end of the day buying and
selling stuff still gets me going in a
way that boggles my mind as many of you
know if you follow my content going to a
garage sale is still the most exciting
thing I can do in business like closing
a nine or closing an eight-figure deal
for Vayner media is nowhere on the same
scale as going to a garage sale and
finding a sixty seven dollar stuffed
animal for a quarter
and I think about
because I'm really saying it no [ __ ]
like it's really where my chemicals are
and and it's funny where I was in my
career when the aggressive reselling on
Amazon and other platforms happened kind
of put me in a place where I wasn't able
to like fully go there because I was so
deep in operating multiple things at the
time but one of the great regrets of my
life is that I didn't have eBay and
Amazon and other platforms as such when
I was in junior high in high school and
had unlimited time because a I wouldn't
have graduated high school and I think
that's kind of cool and B the amount of
learnings that you get from scaled
reselling I think is pretty profound and
has a huge impact I believe selling
things on the internet actual physical
things and or working inside of a retail
store and interacting with tons of
people from all shapes and sizes are
really the two great training rounds for
a framework of a very successful
business because there are many things
that I focus on in HR operations Finance
but the concept of creating demand
is a very very very interesting one
because it sits with so few people when
I think about the room and I think about
the panel and I think about the content
that's been spread demand creation
excites me and will always excite me as
a matter of fact it's the framework of
what I think I want to talk to you about
today which is as I think about the
majority of the room because I know a
lot of people here do different things I
always try to think about what is the
one connective tissue that the room may
have so that what comes out of my mouth
is actual value while I'm on stage and
is universal and comma is potentially
the thing that is not being focused on
the most as a matter of fact the young
lady that was just up here I grabbed her
right before I went oh there she is like
I grabbed her and I said look that Tick
Tock thing you just said was really good
and it's really good because it's really
real and it's really at scale and what I
know and I'm making this assumption so
please
during the Q a the best practices within
the ecosystem
is where a lot of the content will come
from in a conference like this and what
you are consuming and what you know what
I get excited about is what's the best
practices that are not obvious within
the platforms meaning the Amazons and
the Walmarts and the other shopifies and
things of that nature what could you be
doing for me one of the things that's so
interesting is
Global pandemics are going to obviously
create curveballs for supply chain right
so I'm I'm aware of that but I think
about what is consistently going to
matter to every single person in here
for the rest of their careers and that
consistent thing that I want to focus on
today is underpriced attention
underpriced attention is very important
and underpriced attention falls into two
categories math and art what I mean by
underpriced attention is which ad
product today is a good deal I built my
Daddy's Liquor Store like you saw in
that video because I have 90 open rates
on an email newsletter that had a
hundred thousand people on it in 1997.
let me say that nice and slow for
everybody in the back
90 open rates
that's unheard of that's not real in
today's world that 90 went to 50 in the
first two years not because we were bad
at it but because the world had started
using email marketing and people were
getting tired of it but when I was doing
it nobody was doing it and it worked I
bought Google AdWords for the store the
day Google AdWords came out and for the
first year I owned the word wine for
five cents for four months
and then for 10 cents when they raised
the price it used to be a five cent
collect for the first few minutes there
and and then obviously it had to be
Cabernet and then it obviously had to be
Silver Oak Cabernet and then it had to
be Silver Oak 2016 Cabernet and a lot of
you in this room know that the math part
that you play to win in the ecosystems
of where you sell are toll booths
and that's fine they deserve it Amazon
warmer others they deserve it they have
the attention you're paying for it
that's right I love when people get mad
at social networks they're like [ __ ]
Zuckerberg [ __ ] me the algorithm
and I'm like I'm like
it's free
it's [ __ ] free
the audacity of people is fascinating
the platform's free
for every selling marketing person here
everybody the concept of something
that's free that can sell stuff is
insane of course net net it's not free
got a production company things of that
nature but most people when they start
should only be doing it themselves on
their phone and it's free
so
the math part is something that
doesn't interest me to go deep on
because my intuition is a lot of people
play Within that framework you're not at
this place if you aren't relying on some
level of math you understand that the
part that I want to focus on is why I
got so excited about what she had to say
which is the art part
as many of you know iOS 14 5 update
hurts some folks
there's a lot of other things coming
down the pike in moats that are going to
continue to hurt
and what does that mean it means that as
math plays out its game on the internet
and the big corporations play their
politics with each other and play
when I think about smaller businesses
and I'm talking about businesses doing
under 100 million a year in Revenue
under 50 or 25 or 10 we may included
must really understand the art part of
underpriced attention for our businesses
this is all fancy jargon for one simple
thing the single thing that can change
the majority of businesses in this room
is an obnoxious and I mean obnoxious
commitment to organic social media
creative
as
an opportunity to take advantage of the
tick tock of vacation of social media
that will be the next half decade in the
next half decade
The Tick tockification of all social
networks is the biggest opportunity for
everybody in this room what is happening
and will continue to happen is these
platforms are going to reward the
creative not your ability to build the
following this is exciting for everybody
in the room if you heard me loud and
clear because many people here have not
made the commitment to a masking
Community as a personal brand or even
for their brand
when I tell you that you could have
never made a piece of content in your
life and tomorrow for your business your
product or you however you want to play
it both preferably
that you can post your first post on a
YouTube shorts or a tick tock and if you
know what you're doing a lot of good
things can happen for your business is
exciting
the problem is it's daunting for a lot
of people a lot of people in this room
like math it's predictable it's black
and white they hate art it's gray as
[ __ ] and you have no idea what the [ __ ]
is going on
the problem is the math will continue to
get commoditized and will be leveraged
against you
and the art is your moat
branding instead of math-based digital
sales
and marketing and content and creativity
are a Battleground that this room must
take much more seriously than it has in
the last decade because it will be the
protection to allow you to have the
margins you'll need to sustain your
business because what's actively
happening is the math is being run to
take all your margin
let me say it nice and slow
the math is being run to take your
margin when you don't sell product
within your own self when you sell
somewhere else the data is being
collected this is good they deserve it
you brought no customers to the table
they brought all of them
I just need you to know the opportunity
in front of you what does this mean it
means a couple of things one
this Tick Tock a vacation of all social
is a huge opportunity for many reasons
one back to how many of you try many
different products I would argue
in Social
based on these Algos is the greatest
insight
to what your next product should be
the concept of guessing
your next product is crazy in a world
where you can literally create samples
at scale create content against it and
get incredible qualitative feedback if
it's interesting not the math
but the comments and the insights at
scale from free distribution because of
organic virality because that's where
social is going
this is a profound shift
in Social at a time when social is
hitting scale
of complete and utter consumption
patterns besides streaming services
besides gaming and streaming services
the attention of society is living
within these 10 platforms
this is a
I really hope the tenor that I'm
bringing to it which is a little more
serious than my style normally is
landing for some of you because the
stakes are so high because it's pure
offense
again in simplest terms I genuinely
believe that every single business in
this room needs to go home and
substantially and I'm talking two four
Thirty X their creative output per day
for context how many people here are
putting out five pieces of social media
creative for their business a day please
raise your hands
please stand actually if you don't mind
the [ __ ] disaster
thank you for these Pioneers good [ __ ]
thank you
this is actually can you keep these
lights on because I want to see the
crowd thank you so much this is huge for
me personally I come to talks at this
point in my career
singling for the email that I get in
three years from some of you about that
this was the talk that made you do the
thing that made the thing happen
to have an audience of this level of
skill in this category of business and
to have such an extraordinary low
percentage of people that are even
putting out five pieces of content today
in a world where if you're doing
two million dollars in revenue on your
business you should be considering 10 a
day
is just a massive opportunity
again
what we're talking about is something
everyone should fully understand which
is social media is where brand is built
social media is driving an extraordinary
amount of sales
it's also changing in a way that it
hasn't for 15 years the reason I'm
personally so excited about it is in
2006 my life changed because I took all
of my savings all of them and I invested
in three companies
Facebook Twitter and Tumblr
obviously
I'm rich now
but the moral of the story is not that
the moral is when I invested in Tumblr I
called my brother AJ and I said Tumblr
is going to be the biggest one of these
three
thank God I wasn't making videos back
then
Tumblr did sell for a billion dollars to
Yahoo
but let me tell you why I thought Tumblr
was going to be the biggest in 2007.
even back then
there was something in my Spidey senses
that understood the social media social
graph was following each other and
because it started young and I watched
my brother go through it because he was
the first class in college and by the
time we even started vaynermedia half
the people he was following he wasn't
friends with they had different
interests already I understood there was
vulnerability in it just being about who
you followed but Tumblr
I'm 46 so for the 30 year olds 32 year
olds in here 35 year olds in here that
remember tumblr's rise when they were in
junior high
Tumblr was based on what you were
interested in
and I saw stickiness there that I really
was dumbfounded by
that has now been manifested if you look
back and you Google my name with the
word musically you'll see four or five
years ago me screaming at the top of my
lungs that you need to get on musically
when it was I mean I thought I was going
to go to [ __ ] jail
because it was only 13 year old girls on
there dancing
I remember my team's like you sure you
want to post this I'm like [ __ ] it
but I knew I knew what I was looking at
with musically really mattered to
everybody in this room and was going to
at some point obviously Tick Tock bought
it it is now what is tick tock if you
are not active on this for your business
just going to tick tock right now if you
download it today for the first first
time in five weeks because you're
curious about what I'm saying or what
you said earlier if you just searched
the hashtag tick
or maybe because it hit every news cycle
maybe the Ocean Spray story Ocean Spray
cranberry juice has been around forever
the single most effective commercial
marketing campaign in the company's
history was a man going down the street
on some sort of skateboard drinking it
and listening to Fleetwood Mac
in its history
it is impossible for me to be able to
communicate to this room how big of an
elephant in the room what I'm talking
about is for reselling
there is a collision course that is
happening between math and art and the
greatest way for you to extract value is
to bet so much more on Art in the face
of it not being as interesting to bet on
as math
the day-to-day tactics of what I'm
saying
you take your product
and whether through reaching out to
influencers at scale and paying which
can be very underpriced or overpriced
depending on your skill set of
understanding what you're buying and you
should put some real homework into it
but more importantly your ability to
create internal production capabilities
to produce ungodly amounts of short form
video content
is important not just because it goes
viral and maybe you'll sell some stuff
but there's so much more complexity to
it and I'd like to share it with you you
let's just use the boots with the rubber
thing you take the boots you make a
[ __ ] boot video I don't know put poor
champagne in it and drink something out
of the boot like my old Russian uncles
used to you make the video
if the video catches lightning and my
prediction is that these platforms are
about to go more extreme actually how
many people here are producing
social media content for their business
at all like once a day forget about the
five day like at all as a driver for
their business raise your hands
all right a little bit more but still
quite a few not which is just great like
I'm pumped about this
right now because about half the room or
maybe we're just lazy this morning but
about half of them doesn't I just want
to update you on how it's been for the
last five years on Instagram and other
platforms your views were basically in
the same pocket except the occasional
thing right they were in the same pocket
it was so based on who follows you
that's a consistent understanding
in Tick Tock you can post something and
get 600 views the next one 90 and then
the next one's 400 000. I actually think
that extremity over the next decade is
going to get more extreme on every
platform because it's in the best
interest of the people on the other side
so I think those numbers could get as
Extreme as in three years from now we're
getting videos depending on how good you
are at it where you're getting 7 20 50
30 94 million
why is this important today if you take
action this week on this talk as we
clarify through q a which is why I
wanted to do more because I'm sure
there'll be questions and you say [ __ ]
it I'm going to do this
when something goes viral
there's a very substantial thing that
has to happen one and very few people
are doing this at this point you have to
talk turn that brand piece of content
into brand formants
so you take the viral post
and you re-jigger it
you edit it slightly or you change the
copy you change the url potentially even
in your profile and you take it and you
run ads against it as a performance ad
driving to your Amazon your Shopify your
own site or wherever you are
you turn the brand piece of content
because consumers have shown you that
they're interested in it and you turn
that into the creative ad
these creative ads matter because
they're very different than intent based
ads or retargeting ads because they have
a different feeling it's the reason
someone buys your product that really
matters in this scenario and what the
value of that customer is versus
somebody you may submit in a pre-ios
14.5 World on the 17th retargeted ad and
they bought it I mean I know people who
buy stuff just because they got
retargeted so much they just wanted it
to stop and they just bought the [ __ ]
thing
that's not a good relationship
but also it's the insight
one thing that is happening in this
community when I watch it when I see a
lot of you talk with each other on
social when I get the emails in detail
when I talk to my friends that are in it
one thing that we don't spend enough
time in this
realm is I'm the consumer insights from
the comments on the creative a as we
could tell by the room we're not doing
enough creative B we're not spending
time in the comments the comments have
all the insights this goes back to the r
d or what could be the single Insight
that leads to the campaign or the
product advancement that actually takes
you to the next level within your
business many of you are playing such
strong great Arbitrage that you're
looking for the next Arbitrage
without realizing the Arbitrage you
currently have is the play you just have
to build it in a slightly different way
to a different scale that comes from the
marketing side that comes from the art
side that comes from the consumer
insights side
so when the post goes viral the ability
to turn it into a direct response ad
that I know will play for this room is
important but the ability to understand
how to then make a twenty thousand
dollar video that takes the insights you
got from that one piece of social media
ad
and have the ability to turn that twenty
thousand dollar video into a bidable
streaming service ad as a commercial
Hulu Amazon Prime what Netflix is about
to do is the way that a lot more
businesses in here on that single
product go from a million dollar a year
business that's running math Arbitrage
on showing up first in a search result
within a platform to becoming a 57
million dollar a year business on its
own Merit that is not at the mercy of
the toll booths to me that is the most
significant moat and opportunity of the
next half decade for the profile of this
room understanding that if you can get
religious about social media creative
by creating and I'll take it I'll go
even more tactical you've got a product
you step back you decide we need to make
this product relevant for 50 different
consumer segmentations 18 to 22 year old
dudes who skateboard on the west coast
yoga moms in the Pacific Northwest
DieHard Jets fans who grew up in New
Jersey and on and on and on you create
these targets that then helps you make
the content it gives you a framework of
like okay because you know what it is
right I know like what am I going to
make it's like 10 a day [ __ ] you you
know
when you have consumer segmentations you
kind of understand why you're doing it
you can can start conceptualizing to
whom and what you start making this
creative
and you let the algorithms work in your
favor everyone's boo hoo hoo about
algorithms because they wanted a couple
more likes this room can build their
absolute Empire on the back of
algorithms they're empty pipes they
either beat you or you beat them and I
feel like this is a room that wants to
beat them I I really do I don't think
you're at this conference for kicks and
giggles
I also think this room is full of [ __ ]
like every room
because they talk about grinding and
doing things but they tend to stay on
the things they like we all do I do too
and I really understand how awesome it
is when you understand Quant and math
and all these things and you understand
the platforms and how they work and best
practices the problem is that's a
commoditized piece of information
it's just this and of course you can be
outlined in this and that the bigger
problem is the platforms decide when
they want to be more profitable
let me say that one nice and slow
the platforms decide when they want to
be more profitable
so what you need to do is you need to be
able to build demand across all
platforms so that you're not
one-dimensional and you're stuck most
people have one punch
you need to mix it up you need to mix it
up and no question the biggest
opportunity buy a country mile for this
room is to get way more serious about
social media let me tell you why social
media marketing is important for
everybody in this room
do you know what sales is like sales DNA
then I'm so proud of that so many of you
do in here digitally
it's just bad marketing
sales is transactional
these [ __ ]
didn't show up first when I searched
sneakers
they didn't retarget me all over the
Internet nobody knocked on my door and
said would you like this I'm buying this
you understand no question the biggest
opportunity for this room is to make the
product that you want to sell something
that people want to buy
forever
forever
thank you
I uh
by the way I know I produce enough
content that maybe there's something
that I've been putting out that you're
interested in that I didn't decide to
touch on today you could go anywhere
with the Q a but I really appreciate you
guys and I really I hope the tone
antenna is uh is understood by those
that know me in this room this is a very
serious opportunity like it because it's
a double one it's kind of like when I
called all my Russian my dad's Russian
Uncle friends in La when Uber came out
because I was an early investor I was
like this is going to be a problem they
laughed at me
they laughed at me and I'm sure that
there's some people in here doing seven
million dollars a year all on math all
one-dimensional that are not laughing
but are dismissing what I'm saying I'm
telling you this is a double bubble what
a double bubble is is this trend is
going to happen for the next five years
and it's where all the offense is and if
you stay doing exactly what got you to
this room in the VIP at the event it's
going to get harder and worse
it's very clear what's happening please
please pay attention don't get high on
your own Supply
as soon as you feel like it's going well
you're in trouble
[Music]